OK, let me get right into audience questions.
We've gotten so many of them, so many things
are going on, a lot of the topics are understandable
and predictable.
And I want to dig right into the first one.
David, will the protests and civil unrest
be good or bad for Donald Trump in terms of
his approval rating and his reelection chances
in November?
Listen, the answer is very much like it is
on Corona virus.
Donald Trump's response to Corona virus was
a failed nonresponse.
Donald Trump's response on the civil unrest
has been worse than a non-response.
We have a we have unrest that was that started
with what was seen as the brutal unlawful
killing by police of George Floyd and Donald
Trump tweeted in his bunker all weekend.
OK.
He was in his bunker for a few hours, tweeted
from the White House all weekend, including
from the bunker on Friday night, only to come
out on Monday and say we need more police
force.
We need to further militarize law enforcement.
Right.
So they were the worst possible thing that
he could come out and say.
But the trumpet's defended him on Corona virus
and the Trump will defend him on his response.
Mostly will defend him on his response to
the civil unrest.
This works in the short term.
I don't believe that this will work in the
long term.
So, like with everything else, what matters
is how long is this going to go on?
Take coronaviruses.
An example failed response completely failed
response numbers are now starting to improve.
States are opening up whether this will lead
to a huge resurgence of the virus or not.
We don't know what will be happening in September
or October into the November election.
We don't yet know.
But Trump pretending everything is fine even
when it's not only works for so long.
Six weeks ago, Trump said no more of these
press briefings with doctors.
I'll do CEO roundtables, belittle all that
stuff and just basically pretend this is a
business situation rather than a medical situation
in the immediate IT sort of work.
That did get a lot of Trump Estyn right wingers
saying we're back and we're reopening and
sort of disconnected from the realities.
We still had 15 people die in a single day
from Corona virus a few days ago.
So if that continues, Trump's strategy is
not going to work.
Similarly on civil unrest, if protests continue
for months through the summer as coronavirus
doesn't go away.
And Trump seems to be unable to control it,
deploying the military happens with increased
frequency and it is seen as an authoritarian
move from wannabe baby dictator Trump.
A lot of people are going to react negatively.
He will still have the core trumpets that
support him no matter what he does.
As he said, if I could.
You know, I could shoot people on Fifth Avenue.
They'd still vote for me.
He could send soldiers to shoot people on
Fifth Avenue.
And many people would still vote for Trump.
But it is not going to appear to be a strong
Trump.
It is not going to be a Trump that appears
in control even, you know.
Earlier this week, the staged photo op propaganda
event at St. John's Church in DC, where Trump
had protesters tear gassed and dispersed by
police on horses so he could hold the Bible
up the wrong way, like clearly held the Bible
in a way no one who holds a Bible would ever
hold the Bible just to get that picture.
Yeah, some people liked it.
And there were some video edits done of it
on Twitter where it's, you know, with inspirational
music and look at the great President Trump.
It's not going to work for that long.
If the protests continue, the buck at some
point stops with the president, even Trump
said, when there were protests under Barack
Obama.
Nothing like what we're seeing now that it's
Obama's responsibility.
And, of course, it's different rules for Trump.
We know that.
But I do not believe that over the long term
corona virus, continuing is not going to be
good for Trump, no matter how he propagandize
is, because there are factual realities on
the ground.
A continued disastrous economy with 25 percent
of the labor force that was working before
this started 11 weeks ago unemployed.
It's not going to be good for Trump.
Disastrous GDP numbers coming out in late
August.
It's not going to be good for Trump no matter
how he propagandize is in much the same way
if the headlines continue to be things are
out of control.
Yeah, you'll have Republicans saying, oh,
it's all Democratic run.
They'll say Democrat runs cities that are
having a problem.
Well, urban areas are disproportionately Democratic.
It doesn't you know, the cities that are having
problems are mostly run by Democratic mayors.
And the cities that aren't are as well, because
that's the way it works.
We have an urban rural divide in this country.
Those talking points will work for a little
while, but they are not going to work all
the way through to November.
If the unrest continues and Trump seems to
be the flaccid, impotent guy that he is who
can't take control of a situation.
Who can't be presidential, who can't reduce
tensions and rather inflames them.
I think it will dramatically backfire.
And by the way, Joe Biden is no miracle of
progressive values.
You all know that.
But Joe Biden's been giving some pretty sensible
speeches about the unrest and about Corona
virus over the last 10 days.
They've widely not been covered by corporate
media for all of the apoplectic shouting about
liberal corporate media.
They're covering what Trump says and does,
and they're not covering what the challenger
who could be president in only.
What is it now?
Seven, eight months.
He could be inaugurated.
They're not covering what he's saying and
he's making a lot of sense.
I mean, even a lot of the never Biden people
that watch the show wrote to me over the last
few days saying, you know, I'm not.
I've got to vote for Biden.
You know, clearly these guys are not the same.
The last week has proven that.
And Biden's being reasonable.
Imagine if corporate media actually showed
what Joe Biden has been doing and saying.
I think it would be even more disastrous for
Donald Trump.